Lewis wrote in not former producer Louis
but just someone named Louis David what
should we stop teaching our children at
the top of the list for me is we should
stop scaring kids with the irrational
fear of ending up in hell if they don't
do the correct arbitrary things during
their lives I mean we spoke to Lawrence
Krauss who by the way has also been hit
by the me2 movement over the last couple
of months we spoke to astro physicist
Lawrence Krauss about this years ago
which is the question of whether it is a
form of psychological abuse to make kids
scared of an eternal inferno known as
hell for which there is no actual
evidence in order to get them to behave
a particular way during their lifetimes
and Lawrence Krauss felt that the answer
was yes I think we should stop teaching
kids about the possibility that they
will end up in hell right away I think
that it also would be really important
to teach children early on about media
consumption right I think that we have
so many studies so I think if I don't
I'm not speaking for parents but I think
a lot of the research on child media
consumption shows us that very early on
kids start to recognize brands and
characters and branding without actually
understanding that this is media meant
to influence them to make a buying
decision or for kids it's to ask their
parents to buy them something for
example and kids don't understand that
and I think that parents would be very
well served if very early on they
effectively are teaching media literacy
to their kids and it's kind of
depressing that this is something that
has to be taught but kids as young as a
couple or three years old can start to
recognize brands in this way and I think
that the earlier you explain to kids
that what you see on TV is not only not
always real which I think parents tend
to do but it also is I don't know
exactly what the wording would be again
I don't have kids but you would want to
start to explain to them that the there
are things you will see in here that are
trying to influence you and it's good to
develop a healthy
Oh Leon I don't really see that done and
it would be a really good thing I think
kids are able to identify the McDonald's
logo before they can identify their own
last name mmm that's pretty telling yeah
right because that's true kids early on
tend to know their first name but last
name is something that they have less of
a less of a grasp of and I wouldn't be
surprised I think when do kids have
really learned their last names like
around I have no or maybe and I think
certainly they can identify McDonald's
around two or three so yeah that'd be
interesting to see that study anything
else that you you have ongoing what
about this idea that you can tell a kid
that they can do anything they put their
mind to they can grow up to be whatever
they want pursue any career that they
want yeah in a way you know it's
inspiring them and they are full of
potential so maybe they could achieve
those goals yet we also are limited by
our natural ability not everyone's going
to be grow up to become a professional
athlete and also by opportunity so
there's always the same time where
people might have the same equality of
potential but not in practice the same
equality of opportunity because of where
it is that they're growing up or
whatever this this is actually a really
tough one because on the one hand it's
known that developing a sense of
self-esteem early on is really good for
kids long-term at the same time there's
questions about the sort of practicality
of telling kids that it's perfectly
reasonable to think that they could be
astronauts or the president but I
honestly I don't think there's really a
downside because children that exist in
the world in a normal way they will
start to develop a sense of not only
what's possible but what's likely as
they age so I don't think there's any
harm whatsoever in saying you you know a
lot of things in life are about effort
and about showing up and about the
desire to do it and yes that's not a
guarantee that you will be whatever it
is you want to be but I think that the
real world will sort of naturally temper
what might be unreasonable expectations
kids build around that and I don't
really think that that's a huge deal I
bet you were told from an early age that
you could never grow up to be President
of the United States I was you weren't
born in the United States and that's
right you know you turned out okay it
was useful actually for me to be told
that because otherwise I might still be
thinking of running for
president of course legally I can never
be President of the United States unless
the law is changed although the city if
Obama was president why can't I be
president right Bruce I know you're
joking but Ted Cruz ran for president oh
yeah I don't know what the big deal is
after all